a man ananda poodell what do you guys
think of pete holmes's series crashing
i would like it more if i wasn't cut out
of it oh
you would you had you worked hard on
that i remember yeah we did i got paid
which is cool i did a roast uh segment
it was fun i thought the show was a lot
of fun i i mean artie lange
but i mean uh yeah i had i roasted
matteo lane
uh so it was fun he had some great jokes
on me i i got to burn him back we had
fun yeah yeah can you uh let us in on
how they film it because i was told
uh someone else on a podcast was saying
how
they only do the jokes one time in front
of a live audience they don't like
repeat the jokes over and over again
is that true they like to keep keep it
fresh for the crowd no they we would
repeat jokes
they would fake laugh or yeah that's a
show uh i would try to do extra jokes
but yeah i mean i
yeah i think jokes should repeat it i
don't think that's true but uh
mateo is a funny guy too he was funny
yeah it's something on me i forgot he
said i'm like sam loves baskin you can
tell because he's sick three
uh
he uh
he doesn't have a dad and his career is
going to be over by his early 30s
that's pretty good that's pretty good i
do have a dad though
but it does it does hurt the joke but i
think i had something autumn always said
uh
mateo uh
something like uh something about his
mustache having i said you look like you
got freddy mercury poisoning oh that's
great yeah absolutely
there's some [ __ ] like that where was
like uh
matteo is from brooklyn but he spends
all of his time in queens i think eli
sayers gave me that one
that's great too that was a good one
yeah eli sarah shout out to him it was
one of the best some of the best roast
jokes on the planet yeah i forgot what
else i said to him it was fun we had fun
roasting each other and i also was like
he was nervous i was gonna be me and i
was like i will tell you all the jokes
beforehand this is we're acting who
gives a [ __ ] yeah
and they cut it out they were like it
was too much time and i'm like it's hbo
this is no commercials yeah no one gives
a [ __ ] if the episode is 31 or 29 right
yeah roasted i mean i love roast it just
takes so much time i'm over it dude i'm
over it too and i did a million rows
battle we both did you know they're all
over youtube
it's just a lot of work and you want to
work on your act
uh
best roast moment of my life though i
gotta share this here i can't share this
on the real app
[Music]
you